and I spoke to people who had survived
massacres of entire towns who had seen
their family members raped tortured
killed Maria McFarland Sanchez Moreno is
the executive director of the drug
policy Alliance which she joined last
September after over a decade as a drug
policy analyst at Human Rights Watch
she's also the author of there are no
dead here a story of murder and denial
in Colombia her book chronicles that
country's bloody history after the death
of cocaine trafficker Pablo Escobar and
the conflicts among Colombia's military
surviving drug lords left wing
terrorists known as the FARC
paramilitary groups and civil rights
activists the book is also a critique of
how the United States inserted itself
into Colombia struggles in the name of
our own war on drugs
I talked to McFarlane recently at
reasons New York studio Maria thanks for
talking to Reason thanks so much for
having me there are no dead here is
disturbing arresting riveting summarized
the kind of plot line that you're
telling and why it's important that
people in America know about it so the
book starts in the late 90s when
paramilitary groups were rapidly
expanding all over the country these
were right-wing death squads that in
theory were fighting the left-wing
guerrillas of the FARC the reality is
that they were also the country's
biggest drug traffickers they had picked
up the reins of where Pablo Escobar had
and the Cali cartel had left off and
many of them were former Escobar's
associates in fact people who are
familiar with narcos or might know the
the story of the base who helped to kill
Pablo Escobar well the paramilitaries
are descendants of that the u.s. at the
time was pouring billions of dollars
into fighting a war on drugs in Colombia
and in many cases that money was going
to the military and the military was
working very very closely with
paramilitary groups so ultimately what
the US was doing in practice was pouring
money into one side one group of drug
traffickers versus another
you know this obviously in many ways was
an echo of
American kind of intervention in the
1980s a little bit further up in in
Central America or Latin America what
what was the United States trying to
gain by giving money to the military and
effectively the paramilitaries well the
the vast increase in funding came with
Plan Colombia and the idea was there to
supposedly help Colombia fight drug
trafficking and and secure peace and in
theory they said that they were fighting
all drug traffickers and in some cases
the US was working with members of the
Colombian government against
paramilitary groups at one point they
even went so far as to declare the
paramilitaries a foreign terrorist
organization alongside the FARC
and there were efforts to extradite some
of their leaders but in practice it was
very clear that there were Colombian
military units who were working with the
paramilitaries the u.s. knew that
because groups like Human Rights Watch
where I used to work we're telling the
u.s. this it was very clear and they
were just turning a blind eye to that in
many cases because I frankly I don't
know they were they were very committed
to this policy they were very committed
to certain political leaders in Colombia
and and I think it just became too
difficult to deal with the implications
of what was happening there and I mean
part of it I guess was with playing
Colombia you know the end this was a
Clinton era or a Bill Clinton
administration initiative that was
widely supported by everybody and that
it moved into the Bush era as well but
the idea that Colombia and particularly
under Escobar it was something like 80%
or more of the coke that would cocaine
that was coming into America he was he
was bringing directly so if we fix
Colombia then we fix America's cocaine
problem right I mean the whole premise
of the of the war on drugs has always
been that if you focus on the supply
side then you'll solve all the US has
problems with problematic drug use
and that's simply not true we've been
dealing with the war on drugs for what
six decades now and drug use fluctuates
but it's never really gone down
significantly and certainly the attempt
to to kind of tighten down or nail down
the supply deplete it never seems to
work or it doesn't show up in the price
on the street of anything so how you
know the idea being that if if if we
were able to stop cocaine production in
Colombia the price in the US would go up
the street price and fewer people would
use that or at least we would know that
interdiction was working are there ways
in which before we talk about the
effects in Colombia which is really the
heart of the book and it like I said I
mean it's horrifying and impossible to
turn away from what what is your kind of
evaluation of Plan Colombia was it a
complete failure is that a partial
failure what what comes out of that
well Plan Colombia was overwhelmingly
about military assistance portions of it
went to the justice sector or social and
economic assistance and I would say that
that those pieces are important to
maintain because you're talking about a
country that doesn't have the capacity
to hold people accountable when they
commit crimes I mean this is one reason
you have massive atrocities and everyone
gets away with everything on the other
hand I think that to some extent all of
this money is going to waste as long as
you don't deal with the underlying
problem of the illicit market and drugs
which is fueling organized crime on a
massive scale I mean there are so many
profits that can be obtained from that
market that no matter how much money you
put into fighting organized crime
they're always going to be new leaders
who step into the shoes of those who've
been arrested and it's just going to
continue so I mean ultimately then and
we'll talk about this when we talk about
you're relatively recent role a new role
that drug policy Alliance but I mean
until we get rid of a kind of
prohibitionist mindset we
might be able to stop particular drug
flows or killed particular drug lords
but the larger problem cannot be solved
pretty much yeah
so in terms of Colombia I mean you you
focus on a number of figures who are
pretty heroic talk about you know one or
two of those and and why you you know
why you focus on them and what are the
lessons that we can learn from in many
cases their their tragic ends yeah so
the first main character is is a man
called his who's Maria y yeah who in the
late 90s was a human rights activist in
Medellin and in Antioquia generally he
was from a rural area near Medellin and
he started hearing reports from the
people in his home region about
paramilitaries going in there and
killing people ordinary people accusing
them of being FARC guerrillas and trying
to take over control of the area he also
started hearing that they were working
closely with members of the military so
he began speaking out when nobody else
was doing so and he would go to the
governor he would go to the head of the
army in in Antioquia the region he spoke
on TV he wrote articles gave speeches
and repeatedly got shut down people
ignored him people said it's not true at
one point the Army sued him for
defamation the governor who later became
president about Oda allegedly said that
he was an enemy of the armed forces
because of the things he was saying so
so value was left alone with these
allegations and there was a horrifying
massacre that happened in 1997 in
October called the massacre of helado in
which paramilitaries went into a town
killed 17 people including children
tortured it was vicious and then drove
everybody else out of the town
Valley had warned that something was
going to happen he tried to get help and
then later he he repeatedly said you
know the military was involved in this I
have evidence few months later he was
killed in his office in Midian and and
the case was essentially buried nobody
really got to investigate in depth you
know some people tried early on but but
they didn't find the killers until much
later and only in the last month or so
we've been hearing some new information
coming out about about who was behind
his death and my book includes a mount
of information about that as well but
the thing is via inspired other people
and he showed how important it was to
tell the truth and other people then
picked up where he left off and one of
those other people was Ivana burlesque
is a friend of his who was chief
prosecutor for Antioquia at the time he
tried to conduct investigations of the
paramilitaries and 11 of his
investigators in the course of one year
got killed for those investigations they
at one point found all of the accounting
records of the paramilitaries they
started tracing those records two
prominent people in the region and that
investigation got shut down
apparently by more senior people in the
attorney general's office and after the
investigators were killed Yvan said he
was asked to resigned and to resign and
that ended but years later he ended up
on the Supreme Court of Colombia and he
led what became that known as the pair
of politics investigations where he
documented links between the Colombian
Congress and paramilitary groups and
showed how paramilitaries had helped
members of Congress engage in electoral
fraud and a third of the Clemen Congress
ended up investigated and many of them
in prison for working with
paramilitaries and that in turn led to
you know in conjunction with other
efforts a situation where suddenly a lot
of the truth about the paramilitaries
was coming out and even though Colombia
still has serious problems and
descendants of paramilitaries are still
out there committing crimes I think it
could be much much worse if all of that
hadn't come out so there are good
lessons you know it's a terrible that
people had to die to get to this point
but it's also true that even in the
darkest of times if you stand up for
principle as these people did you can
prevail right and you'reyou're
cautiously optimistic I mean Colombia
has negotiated what seems to be a decent
piece of court with the FARC so I mean
now how you know are you optimist or how
optimistic how cautious are you about
optimism for Colombia I think it's
complex for the same reason I was
mentioning before about organized crime
they do have a peace deal with the FARC
and it may well be that that actor in
the conflict or much of it does
disappear does enter the political
system and as even one of the characters
notes that might help to take away one
of the excuses that paramilitaries and
other people and the right have had for
for persecuting people on the left you
know and killing them and so on
however I think that as long as you have
the illicit drug market you're going to
have actors out there who want to
control territory and we're already
seeing examples of armed groups going
into areas that the FARC left and taking
over control because the state doesn't
have the capacity to protect or control
those areas and frankly with so much
money they can just corrupt police and
military officers and it became it
becomes very difficult to resist efforts
by armed groups to go in what is your
take on Donald Trump has been president
for a year you know if nothing else he
hasn't articulated a lot of clear
policies on a lot of things he seems to
be very personally anti-drug how is that
affecting foreign policy in the Trump
administration and you know and
particularly Latin America well at least
when it comes to Colombia I think people
have been pretty shocked by the way
Trump has treated the country because
here's a country that has suffered
devastating losses in the name of the
war on drugs and throughout Plan
Colombia they you know the government at
least was always trying to portray
itself as the u.s. is best partner in
Latin America and suddenly Trump comes
out and says I'm going to decertify you
as a partner in the war on drugs simply
because they started trying to do things
a little differently you know the
background to this is that in the last
couple of years Colombia said they were
going to stop aerial fumigation of coca
crops and there has been an increase in
coca cultivation there also you know is
this deal with the FARC and Trump
doesn't seem to look upon it very
favorably so so that might be what's
driving Trump I don't think he
articulated it in a great deal of detail
but I think it did come as a shock to
Colombians and you know I think for
Latin America experts it's kind of
surprising also given how close the US
and Colombia have been in the past let's
talk about the drug policy Alliance what
are what are your priorities as
executive director and you you became
executive director last August right
September sometimes yes oh yeah so I
think we have to focus on three things
right now
one obviously we have to look at
overdose this has been a priority for
human right for drug policy Alliance for
a long time we've been pioneers working
on on overdose and pushing for harm
reduction solutions in other words
measures that recognize that some people
are going to use drugs problematically
and that we should try to reduce the
harms associated with that as well as
reducing harms associated with
criminalization
and so we've been pushing very hard for
measures like supervised consumption
sides where people can who are going to
use drugs anyway can use them in under
the supervision of trained professionals
who can monitor them for overdose stop
the overdose if necessary and provide
referrals for other services or
treatment if that's what they want we've
been pushing for access to naloxone the
overdose reversal medication not only in
the hands of first responders but also
in the hands of people in the community
people who are closest to those who are
likely to overdose that seems to be
gaining a fair amount of acceptance if
not quite popularity both among law
enforcement and first responders and
people at large right yeah absolutely no
locks on has gained a great deal of
traction 9-1-1 Good Samaritan laws also
have been gaining a lot of traction and
we've been working on those for a while
but we do want to see more of a move on
supervised consumption sites and on
complete packages of harm reduction and
also against state measures that
undermine those moves for example we've
documented recently how many prosecutors
in states that have been very hard hit
by the overdose crisis are pressing
drug-induced homicide charges so charges
against people who share drugs with a
friend or maybe sell some small amount
who are often people who use drugs
themselves charging them with murder
when there's an overdose which doesn't
solve anything it's not been shown to
have any deterrent effect it just locks
somebody up for decades when that's the
person who themselves has problems and
it makes it less likely that people will
call 911 because they don't want to be
prosecuted so it undermines the effects
of the 911 Samaritan laws but so that's
one piece of it and it's also responding
to trump in sessions because their
approach is very much at least if you go
by their rhetoric very much an
old-school
you know let's double down on the war on
drugs let's go after dealers and that's
what's what got us here in the first
place the fact that people are afraid of
talking about their personal drug use of
seeking help that there is no help
because there's been no investment in
that kind of assistance in so many
places means that people are going to be
underground and are much more likely to
overdose now on the one hand you have
you know the opioid crisis or and you
know whether it's cheap heroin or
pharmaceuticals that are being used in
various ways you have that going on it
seems to be intensifying on the other
hand we have throughout the country
growing acceptance of marijuana
legalization and a de-escalation or a
demobilization of the war on drugs what
what's going on there and how is drug
how is DPA working to kind of further
the positive I don't want to say the
positive side of the war on drugs but
you know the places where the war on
drugs is kind of you know that the drug
warriors are declaring an honorable
peace and trying to get the hell out
well I wouldn't say the drug warriors
are declaring an honorable peace even
with Trump it's interesting when he was
a candidate he said that pot
legalization should be handled at the
state level obviously Jeff Sessions has
said something recently that it's like I
don't care about that I mean I'm I want
federal prosecutors to enforce federal
laws it remains to be seen where that's
going on but certainly Gallup has you
know polls out showing something like
61% including 50 percent of Republicans
now believe that essentially pot should
be treated like beer wine and alcohol so
something is changing right public
opinion has changed dramatically on
marijuana and definitely a majority a
substantial majority in the countries in
favor of legalizing marijuana for adult
use and I think we're going to keep
saying progress on that front even
though Jeff sessions is clearly trying
to stop that and I would not be
surprised if US attorneys emboldened by
sessions did try to prosecute you know
some easy target in some of the states
that have legalized I would not
underestimate know the aggressiveness
and in the Department of Justice now but
I don't think they're going to stop the
progress and that's why you saw suddenly
even after sessions is the rescission of
the cold memo you saw a Vermont come out
and legalize
and and you're going to keep seeing
other states legalize medical marijuana
and legalize marijuana itself now beyond
that we are trying to do two things one
is make sure that marijuana legalization
is done more the way it was done in
California so with provisions for
example for record expungement to right
the wrongs of the war on drugs to make
sure that the communities that have been
most affected by marijuana prohibition
also have access to the market and are
not just excluded by you know the babies
that you men that would be a horrible
thing isn't it - you know during
Prohibition periods you focus a lot of
the violence and a lot of the activity
in poor neighborhoods or inner-city
neighborhoods and then when it becomes
legal you kind of cut them out of the
possible profits right so I mean white
and black and brown people all use drugs
at exactly the same rate so that's
including marijuana and yet black and
brown people are arrested at many times
the rate of white people and that's a
reflection of where police has put it
have put their resources they've
targeted certain communities and it's
great if you can decriminalize marijuana
or legalize marijuana and no longer
enforce in those states but then you
need to fix all of those records of
people who are now walking around with
convictions and can't get jobs can't get
housing have a series of problems
because of those records and you have to
give them access to the market to start
making amends for all of the wrongs that
we're done the other issue here that we
need to look at is how to protect the
states where marijuana is legal from the
federal government and you already have
the Rohrabacher for Amendment which is
attached to spending bills and we have
to reattach it to every new spending
bill to protect states where there's
medical marijuana so it bars the Justice
Department from using federal money to
go after medical marijuana in those
states what we'd like to see is
something like the McClintock amendment
that's been proposed in the past which
would apply that to states where adult
use is legal as well which is also kind
of comforting I mean oh you know
Rohrabacher McLintock these are
kind of right-wing libertarian
conservative Republicans who are at the
forefront of this which shows you know
some like a new consensus well this is
not a partisan issue and marijuana is
certainly not a partisan issue now I
think that the other thing we need to be
looking at is decriminalization of
personal use of all drugs I think that
there's an opening now both because of
marijuana legalization but also because
of what people are seeing with the
overdose crisis explain yeah I mean I I
understand it but I want to make sure
that you know our audience does and that
I fully do the difference between
decriminalization and legalization in
this context for all drugs so when
you're talking about decriminalizing
you're just talking about personal use
and possession so you're saying that
people who have drugs for personal use
which is typically defined as not having
too much too many drugs right so it's
it's a personal standard looking at
intent for some people set threshold
limits there are different ways of
defining it but but basically people who
have drugs for personal use should not
be arrested for possessing or using
those drugs you shouldn't be facing a
loss of your liberty simply for your
personal choices about what you choose
to consume as long as you're not harming
somebody else if you harm somebody else
you know if you neglect your children if
you commit a crime a different crime
under the influence and harm others then
it might be legitimate to criminalize
but simply because you possess drugs for
personal use you shouldn't be facing
prison and the data is incredible
possession for personal use is a single
most arrested offense in the country
we're talking about 1.25 million arrests
for simple drug possession every year
that's you know hundreds of thousands of
people in prison that millions 135,000
are
hind bars for that and you think I mean
I was going to ask what are the lessons
from the you know increasingly
successful campaign to kind of normalize
and legalize marijuana use this is one
of one of the lessons that can be
learned is that if you start with
decriminalization of certain types of
drugs it people will understand that
this isn't going to lead to massive
amounts of use but it will minimize a
lot of the harms that are associated
with drug prohibition yeah I mean it's
different from marijuana legalization
where in marijuana legalization you're
talking about legalizing the
distribution the sales of production all
of that it's a it's a much bigger step
and I don't think the u.s. is in a place
yet where you know you're going to see
any state go in that direction with
other drugs but I think decriminalizing
personal use could do a tremendous
amount of good it could mean that you
start having people come out to the
surface no longer be afraid to ask for
help and you could then have much more
effective public health interventions
for people who actually do have
problematic drug use and yet the truth
is other states have decriminalized
personal use of drugs like Portugal has
some countries never criminalized in the
first place like Spain and when Portugal
decriminalize you didn't see any
significant increase in drug use and
instead you saw a dramatic decrease in
overdose and and other negative
consequences they invested in in the
public health side but the results have
been pretty spectacular well hopefully
we'll we'll be you know learning how it
affects Americans too decriminalization
I want to thank Maria McFarland for
talking to us she is the executive
director of the drug policy Alliance and
she's the author of the new book there
are no dead hear a story of murder and
denial in Colombia Maria thanks for
talking thank you so much for reason I'm
Nicholas Pia
[Music]